whoa that's a methods I rating
Grandmaster shade who is that no name
let's pull an idea I just wanted to be
sure so let's see play my a normal stuff
let's not many more that yeah
interesting question do i play my old
chi Corinne because I know what I'm
doing Evan yeah let's do it once again
at least I'm quick with playing this
line that's not the most testing in my
opinion the most testing is what
Grandmaster neighbor played against me
and 2014 with a 5 closing the queenside
I mean this is also probably good for
smarter to a small advantage for white
but it's not as so much of a problem
Bishop age 6 is actually in precise
because that loses a temple after night
f7 he cannot really i mean he doesn't
want to give up his bishop and then has
to retreat to e3 it's a bit surprising
that he went for that not quite sure if
what what if he has a particularly
threatening idea with it shaking is not
really dangerous on GSM know me
so yeah I one like one or two tempe with
that and what what i want to do is I
want to trade all the rooks if I get the
books traded i'm normally in good shape
that's a decent shape cannot call it I
mean it's just add as it is it's okay
it's funny I'm trying to play it for the
for the eight file ok I don't know I
wanted to prepare this some Bishop to b6
it's not quite clear that I want to do
this it also had rupee eight ok now we
now we trade this stuff now so I go I
get queen bee Aidan that's that's
totally fine at least that's what I
think I think I should be okay after the
Queen trade queen should be six
and night might come over to a three but
I get two nite to c7 covering b5 what
I'd like years of course treat the dark
squared bishop but not so sure I manage
that yeah at least I have some
experience with his position this is
good I can play relatively quickly what
is he going for Knight f3 or something
just sits there and before it's not
helping wonder if night 86 is an idea
for c4 be4 can try before and let's do
it i'm not not not sure he might close
it down but okay this is not it's not
really dangerous i believe
I know it's not particularly thrilling
but this is this is what it is Bishop
age six and something that I'd like to
do night f5 is not an idea no I can till
you get a couple of times so this should
be good and I'm fired on the clock as it
happens with this line because i have
played it so often i don't know if that
helps but looks kind of useful he still
doesn't have a check or any tactics so i
can approve this a little bit and now
here i wonder g5 he probably shuts down
completely yeah okay I'm going back
we not much to do I mean I'm perfectly
okay but I don't really see okay in
place this I don't know if h5 is an idea
let's do this let's try to do a little
something maybe I shouldn't have done
that I mean I could have just stayed and
nothing happens but seems still kind of
interesting probably probably is he's
okay the abbot I've got it I've got more
time but I want to do something I just
just don't want to shuffle around I'm
not only gas
can I do something here fatigue and 95
probably not is that something else I
can go to a five and look here and then
shuffling over to e5 maybe he tries to
enter from the back interesting nice
just goes damn that doesn't really help
yeah but I don't I don't really have
anything I can offer me wrong you're our
third seem trying to do something here
gain drawn I mean it's really download
time and if anybody maybe black gap but
but it's also at mean I really didn't
see what to do probably probably that
wasn't a real way to win with g5 maybe I
can do something else but probably not
really i mean i can drawing it's no
problem at all after the dark squared
bishop Sargon there's absolutely nothing
that what can play for I mean if I just
want the draw i can go g5 and when we
shake hands right here but i tried and
500 he can you can do this now then aged
six okay maybe this is this is a way to
to do something but it's right so it's
so we're closed you can just stay yeah
like this 92 it's probably a draw the
sometimes happens in this line when
everything gets I mean if white to allow
us the trades on the April and queens on
and so on then it's um it's difficult
to make something of all of this and
well I spent one minute 434 moves and
the position is this really I think okay
I don't know yeah maybe here engine
gives 95 this is false maybe an idea I
saw that sorry I sweat a little bit too
late because this hangs and you cannot
go age form so he has to take and this
might be interesting even though the
position is so blocked him now that's it
just all so just very George it can go
something like a three if you just
really wants the draw then f3 they don't
see why playing for more here you can
basically also just shuffle around yeah
it's very Jewish type of position down
because of the complete closure of the
position okay well thanks for watching